alors marié amélie elle a fait un truc
tout en douceur elle a travaillé autour
du mimosa en lui donnant quand même un
peu plus de caractère avec la tubéreuse
c'est ça fait très parfois pour jeune
fille sage c'est le moment de
l'évaluation les élèves soumettent le
parfum qu'ils ont créée au nez du maître
nicolas de bari
il a fallu choisir ses fragrances
sandrine vient de normandie
elle a opté pour des ingrédients qui
reflète sa personnalité
c'est une base vous gère avec de la
verveine du lavandin la bergamote de la
limette et en fait ça correspond assez à
ma personnalité parce que je suis
quelqu'un d'assez discrète je fais créer
mes parfums est en fait le but en menant
à cette formation c'est de créer
moi-même
voilà quelques parfums est aussi de
proposer des ateliers et c'est vrai que
j'ai une forte demande en ce qui
concerne la parfumerie naturel dans
cette master class
il y a les initiés comme sandrine et les
novices qui profitent de l'été pour
s'adonner à l'art de la création de
parfum
j'aime beaucoup les odeurs et je voulais
vraiment avoir cette expertise et une
première expérience il y avait des
odeurs dont j'entendais parler notamment
le benjoin la mire si on n'a pas acheté
le flacon est bien on sait pas ce que ça
sent donc on rêve un peu dessus et là ça
m'a déjà permis de connaître ça j'en
suis je vous fait sentir ou deux il faut
du temps pour maîtriser son art les
techniques c'est pas très difficile en
une semaine mais man initiants va
arriver à créer des parfums fall ont
ensuite travaillé pour maîtriser les
choses et ensuite faire vraiment ce
qu'on a envie de faire c'est à créer
vraiment des parfums originaux et si on
a du talent award du génie en faire des
particulièrement beau pour atteindre le
beau il faut du temps les huit apprentis
ont désormais toute la vie devant eux
pour se prêter à l'alchimie du parfum